aujourd'hui à bonjour à tous et à toutes
tonton david bonjour bonjour si je vous
présente comme le pape français du
raggamuffin c'est une définition qui
vous convient non ça serait un peu
flatteur on dira un jeune qui fait une
nouvelle musique et basta la définition
du raggamuffin c'est quoi en gros c
c'est plus une attitude qu'une musique
en fait c'est plus une manière de
prendre les chaussées plus débrouillards
la musique ce sera plus du reggae
digital du reggae du reggae que de la
génération 90 on dirait on fait quoi
tonton david si je vous invitais ce
matin c'est parce que vous faites en ce
moment 1
un tour de france qui remporte un succès
formidable si vous êtes un domaine où on
a beaucoup bossé mais c'est vrai qu'au
nez quand même surpris parce que
vraiment vrai ça se passe ça se passe
pas mal on en avait déjà filmé qui te
tourner l'année dernière qui s'était pas
passé aussi bien là c'est bien mon
pistons en plaine du rhône encore
quelques dates étaient aussi bien et
demain soir c'est la cigale à paris la
consécration quasiment on peut l'appeler
comme ça vous avez quand même je fais un
chemin formidable depuis peuples du
monde je suis issu d'un peuple qui a
beaucoup souffert
on vous amène plagier les inconnus ont
fait à partir de là auteuil neuilly
passy ça vous monte à la tête ce succès
n'ont pas vraiment disons que ça ça nous
a donné du crédit pour travailler c'est
vrai qu'on depuis serait qu'on travaille
pas mal donc je dis à chaque fois on a
fait on a apparu sur une compilation
pour cynthia se passe pas mal
puis après on a fait 1 45 ça se passe et
on s'est dit tiens ça se passe vraiment
pas mal et puis après on a fait un album
et puis on s'est dit tiens ça se passe
de mieux en mieux et maintenant on fait
de la scène hippie c'est terrible alors
c'est terrible le dernier album c'est
le blues des racailles qui paraît en ce
moment en compact chez virgin pourquoi
le mousse des racailles alors
premièrement c'est ce sera paris chez la
baignoire et de la belle et virgin sont
que les éditions maintenant le blues des
recueils pourquoi parce qu'un blues
comme je dis c'est un peu cynique un peu
amer
beaucoup d'humour c'est le blues
musicalement c'est à pas mal d'un procès
c'est la musi sais c'est quoi c'est la
musique que des esclaves c'est c'est la
musique au quotidien c'est plus ça pas
beaucoup de rigueur beaucoup de feeling
et puis en fait c'est un peu ce à quoi
renâclent 20h ce blues des racailles il
commence par une chanson c'est comme ça
que ça s'appelle c'est votre cv votre
curriculum vitae né en 67 respect papa
merci la mater origines réunionnaises
galère dans les banlieues à bobigny
et puis en 87 fleury mérogis le cjd le
centre pour jeunes délinquants
c'était grave je crois que je voudrais
la question se pose pas d'un bon on va
pas dire que c'était pas grave
maintenant c'est ce qui est important en
fait c'est surtout si on a fait si j'ai
pas mort c'est aussi personnelle que mon
cv pour commencer l'album double zéro
kayes c'est pour bien montrer à la
limite que bon on n'est pas là pour cela
a commenté quand je dis cela raconté on
n'est pas là pour pour essayer d'avoir
une réputation de terribles c'est juste
pour essayer de montrer à quel point une
démarche optimiste et positive même
après ce qu'on a pu mais est ce que
c'est ça qui vous a inspiré
à qui la faute dont on va écouter un
extrait et surtout écouter les paroles
à qui la faute
[Musique]
l'avocat demande à guy laroche mais tout
le monde parle de violence à guilavogui
la faute à qui la faute
mais tout le monde parle de violence
mais un gay la faute à kehl affronter
des gens tant dans la came d'un faut
savoir que c'est l'état des déchets sous
le nez des plus pauvres quatre coins que
tu as raconté les sens de l'art aux
délinquants faudra vite la violence la
cam
à qui la faute pour les jeunes à paris
la vie n'est pas rose à qui la faute
alors je vous pose la question la faute
à qui on pourrait dire simplement que
c'est c'est la faute de ceux qui
contrôlent ce serait pas bon on va dire
ce qui comptera c'est qu'ils n'ont en
fait là c'est la faute à tout le monde
en fait parce que je crois
qu'aujourd'hui on vit on vient malaise
qui est dû un problème de masse mais
qu'est réglables individuellement quoi
ça j'en suis sûr c'est certain en fait
c'est vraiment un problème d'éducation
et tout la preuve d'éducation il ya
quand je dis l'éducation c'est pas
forcément la scolarité et c'est pas
forcément l'éducation parentale
c'est tout ce qu'on vit aujourd'hui vous
avez quasiment un ministre pour vous
tout seul sa nomination a été une
surprise dans le gouvernement de
monsieur bériault ss et bernard tapie
alors est-ce que vous avez un message à
lui adressé ce matin il est en train de
préparer des mesures qui va présenter au
conseil des ministres la semaine
prochaine tapie comment vous le
ressentez vous avec toujours face à hull
pas mal de la promotion quand même
maintenant je sais que c'est bien
attention quand je dis c'est bien ça
mieux mais si tu aurais beaucoup
d'appréhension parce que tu es mieux
aujourd'hui c'est monsieur bernard tapie
hier c'était le conseil régional de
telle région qui faisait ça
avant-hier c'était sain et puis en fait
tu te rends compte vite que bon dans ta
cage d'escalier c'est toujours la même
chose tu as toujours les mêmes problèmes
il ya vraiment des gros problèmes dans
les banlieues et pas que dans les
banlieues attendait dans des quartiers
dans paris et où il ya vraiment des
groupes
blême qui qui sont dus à impact man des
bons on essaie d'oublier des jeunes en
fait et c'est donc si je comprends bien
tapi vous attendez de voir un juge vers
vraiment quoi parce que ce sera pas
c'est pas une histoire de de construire
de deux salles de boxe ici ou de mettre
un terrain de foot à côté il ya des
jeunes comprend vite jouer au foot et
compositeur de boxe et il faut en être
conscient contentant davide est ce que
vous considérez comme un modèle
aujourd'hui votre réussite parce que
vous gagnez de l'argent aujourd'hui est
ce que vous êtes un modèle pour tous ces
jeunes de banlieues qui sont pour mais
non moi j'aurais jamais voulu être un
modèle déjà mais j'essaye de de faire
vivre un rêve parisien en fait quoi
j'aimerais bien j aurais bien
qu'aujourd'hui
à paris on parle de rêve de parisiens ou
de rêve de new york ou de brooklyn quoi
en fait
alors quand on a vite pour finir je vais
vous demander une faveur est ce que vous
pouvez me toaster quelque chose en
direct toaster c'est quoi tous tes ce
chat
allez on y va c'est pas le conservatoire
qui m'a construit qui m'a construit man
c'est ma cité dédicacé pour tous les
jeunes qui sont là mais qui bien pour 18
des jeunes thons v damez d'où j'arrive
mende
de la cage d'escalier gd l'iris qui
choque mais c'est la réalité
merci tonton david je rappelle que vous
êtes à la cigale de m'asseoir et que
vous publiez le blues des racailles
le blues des racailles en compact disc
lassabe rien on va y arriver
et puis
à qui la faute dont on a entendu un
extrait dans ce journal et qui paraît
également en clip merci bonne journée
[Musique]